les médecins espagnols tire le signal
d'alarmé pour la première fois depuis 25
ans les professionnels de santé du
secteur public ont entamé un mouvement
de grève national
ils protestent contre un décret du
gouvernement espagnol publié en
septembre qui permet d'affecter les
médecins quelle que soit leur spécialité
à d'autres services hospitaliers en
fonction des besoins
une décision qui selon les représentants
syndicaux menacent le système de santé
publique du pays
aujourd'hui nous médecins devront lancer
une grève nationale face à ce qui met en
danger la santé de tous les espagnols et
constitue l'attentât le plus important
qu'ils aient été perpétrés contre le
système de santé publique espagnole
contre la sécurité des patients est
aussi contre nos droits en tant que
travailleurs selon la confédération
nationale des syndicats de médecins
près de 85 % d'entre eux ont pris part à
cette grève la plupart de manière
symbolique en étant malgré tout auprès
de leurs patients
fortement sollicités depuis plus de six
mois pour lutter contre l'épidémie de
coronavirus les praticiens sont à bout
de souffle
il réclame plus de reconnaissance de la
part du gouvernement
donnons le maximum bien sûr mais il
arrive un moment où quand on vous
demande toujours plus et vous ne voyez
aucune sorte de compensation
je ne dis pas économique mais stabilité
et reconnaissance professionnelle
il y à un moment où le mal est très très
très grand nous pensons que la situation
est intenable
nous disons oui un système de santé
publique mais pas au détriment de la
dignité et de la qualité de vie des
professionnels de la santé
nous traversons beaucoup pour être ici
nous ne pensons pas qu'il nous valorise
c'est dans ce contexte de défiance que
pedro sanchez a présenté ce mardi le
projet de loi de finances pour l'année
2000 21
le gouvernement espagnol prévoit une
augmentation d'environ 3 milliards
d'euros pour le budget destiné à la
santé publique une hausse principalement
destinés à l'achat de vaccins et au
renforcement du réseau public de
médecins généralistes